[Music]
this is gay culture 101. how many times
have you said the most obscene things to
somebody your skin would peel off and as
they're leaving you're like what was
your name
that goes on or off grinder and it's so
like it's so it's so stressful it is
very stressful it is a very stressful
world they're like oh I have I went to
the Olive Garden one time and I'm like
okay I'm not on grinder to talk about
the Olive Garden like I'm I'm searching
for dick but you know sometimes you have
fun conversations with people it wants
your attention at all times and I'm like
this is too much for me do you mind if I
ask if you're as a verse top bottom very
bottom
you've been able to spend a lot of time
with some incredible comedians you know
one that comes to mind for me is Chelsea
Handler if I was with her yesterday see
I love Chelsea so much she's the and you
know what's fascinating about Chelsea is
like when you meet her she's exactly how
she is on TV and she's in real life and
such a supporter like will text me out
of the blue and be like congrats I saw
you did this like he's like a big
supporter of young Comics I love Chelsea
I can't say enough good things about her
I only recently found out that the sun
and the moon are not the same thing
being gay and growing up around my time
I just didn't I never I didn't see a gay
man do stand-up comedy until I was 23.
so I was like most gays watching Joan
Rivers and Kathy Griffin and Margaret
Cho and Wanda Sykes like I was going
towards these women that I was obsessed
with and Chelsea Handler was one of them
you are on tour right now to get back
out on the road and be able to be in
front of a live audience that must feel
incredibly special Canada is the start
of my heater tour which is is a dream
for most Comics to be able to go I mean
I love doing comedy clubs but sometimes
you're screaming over people who are
trying to order mozzarella sticks or get
too drunk or then the checks come out
you're trying to build a set you're like
40 minutes in all the checks come out
and everyone's ignoring you because
they're like who ordered those and I'm
like I
art so a theater like what an
appropriate place like you know that
that's the reward for me and I'm
starting I'm starting it here in Canada
for you to be somebody who is really
Forefront in the comedy scene man all
these questions you're doing great
there's like don't mind me okay don't
throw me off okay but for you you know
like you said there weren't a lot of
queer comedians to look up to when you
were growing up to be that person for
somebody what does that mean for you my
job and my mission is to focus on being
as funny as I possibly can and if
someone takes something from that that
means something to them then that's
that's a beautiful thing I was inspired
when I came back in my day
um when I came out I didn't hear gay
people in my my I listened to a podcast
that doesn't exist anymore but it was
three gay men from Chicago it was
interesting because it was the first
time I'd heard gay people have a sense
of humor I that I didn't realize that
that was a thing I thought if you were
gay everyone was sad you had to hide
yourself you had like it was all shame
based and I was listening to these three
20 year old gay guys just laughing about
everything I that I still hold on to
that as like my little treasure
hey thanks for watching ET Canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos